joining me here on the uh on the rich
eisen show like for instance
maybe maybe you didn't care the way that
the packers drafted you know what i mean
like that sort of thing
right well done he's one of our favorite
guests i love watching him play i just
love everything that uh the way that he
goes about his business
um he's a super bowl champion he is a
future hall of famer he is the
quarterback of the 2-0 green bay packers
he's aaron rodgers how are you aaron
i'm doing good rich thanks for having me
back on it's been a while thank you very
much it has it has been too long how's
life
for you sir how's everything good
everything good different
it's different it's good it's just
strange been a strange 20 20. it has
been what was it like going on the road
i mean that had to be weird awkward even
though it was not a very long trip for
you
but that had to be something right yeah
really strange you know just uh
to go from last year playing there for
the division in week 16 and
uh just how rock and uh us bank can be
there in minneapolis and then
uh to just have no zero you know no
energy
really in the in the building at all was
really strange and then obviously lambo
being empty that that you know we were
showing a shot of empty lambo at the top
of our broadcast on sunday morning and
it just looked weird to me
you know what was it like for you
playing in there aaron
that'd be something yeah oh man probably
the weirdest experience of my career i
would say
here you know just this place has been
uh
you know so special so many memories in
green bay and lambeau
and then just so many things that make
game day game day that
you know people who have come and seen
me over the years and come to games at
lambeau
you know just marvel at and laugh about
whether it's the tailgating and just how
inviting and welcoming you know our fans
are
to not only like you know people who are
from out of town or other teams fans you
know it's always hey come grab a bra and
a beer and
hang out to just the actual things that
happen on game day you know roll out the
barrel and the ymca
and the signs that people bring and you
know it's just
it's a throwback you know kind of city
and time and obviously we're one of the
oldest organizations in the league and
there's just there's just some really
fun things that
that kind of make up uh lambeau field
game day that
i really missed last sunday 2-0 green
bay packers though aaron rodgers so
that's something that you're
you've experienced before um and also in
terms of experiencing before i had kurt
warner on an hour one
and he said that just watching you
through the first two weeks
you look as comfortable as you've looked
in say your mvp seasons that when you're
comfortable
with the offense and players that you
have around you that you
uh excel to the point where you've been
excelling this year would you agree with
an assessment like that that you're
comfortable aaron
yeah i'm not gonna uh not gonna say that
uh
kurt is off there at all you know i
think that's that's a big part of
playing
quarterback is is just feeling your way
uh
your way around everything and and i
think this year second year in the
system
the you know the time we spent in the
off season on zoom meetings
i think simplifying some areas of the
offense
adding to other areas that we felt good
about
i think has really paid off um you know
it's it's for me that's what it's really
been about and then i've
been about just kind of fine tuning some
things
you know i've always been at my best
when i've been able to time
up from a rhythm standpoint of balance
and
you know really time up the routes with
my drops and
i just think last year there was just so
many moving pieces
uh mentally and then personnel wise
you know being second year in the system
has really allowed me to to kind of
relax and
and be that much more comfortable and i
think
you know just getting to know matt and
his his style of play calling i think
this has been a really nice start to our
second year together yeah now what
let's get into that a little bit more
because as you i'm sure you you know the
narrative was that uh
you uh in your um you know second
end of your decades in this league um
with a new coach
um that this you were a leopard with
spots and he's another guy that comes in
and that maybe it wouldn't mesh uh what
what is the play calling that you
that you now know a little bit more
about what about that relationship
currently aaron yeah rich i think it's
about the rhythm of it
i just you know when i was with mike for
so many years you could start to almost
anticipate the calls and hear kind of
the beginning of the calls
and you could finish them in your mind
as he was saying them and i think that's
that's really been
the biggest jump for me in comfort is to
start to hear the rhythm of the calls
uh anticipate what they're going to be
and then be able to finish them before
before he's done finishing and that's
when i mentally know i'm at a really
good place and it just it's different
when you're in one system for
you know 14 years with similar language
for 14 years
and a new one comes in it just takes a
little bit to kind of see the pictures
in your mind
and i think this you know the end of
last year this off season
training camp really gave me uh the
comfort that i could really start to see
him in my mind and anticipate those
calls
and then from a rhythm standpoint i just
really feel like
you know all the uh conversations that
we've had uh over the off season a lot
of them were
uh myself and matt and nathaniel hackett
our coordinator and lou getze
a quarterback coach and a lot of it was
uh you know kind of some philosophical
things that
it was just fun the fun to collaborate
on and just understanding his mind even
more
these are just conversations that we
couldn't have in the first year of the
system because we were just so
we're just trying so hard to get the
system in to you know
meld anything from the previous system
that i liked
and uh and kind of get on the same page
from the terminology so this was a fun
offseason to really
collaborate and be creative and and just
kind of see uh
you know even more into his uh you know
his philosophy and then how he likes
colin plays aaron rodgers here on the
rich eisen show
um a couple of narratives i want to
throw at you here to you tell me if this
is true anything
anything to it because this is what
we're all talking about out there and
what
i'm sure you've heard one about you and
one about the guy you're facing
coming at this week uh the narrative
that you
based on the way that your team drafted
have a monster chip on your shoulder
this year and the way that you've shown
up the first two weeks
um would support that theory and
narrative what do you say to that aaron
rodgers
i think i've always found inspiration
from various things and
as a younger player you know even before
i got in the league you know there was a
lot of slights that i felt about
uh you know the uh scouting of my
performance and my
abilities and who thought i could play
and couldn't play i think as
you know as i got older you've had to
find new ways to to be inspired by
things
i think if anything it's it's almost the
opposite i'm i'm completely at peace
with where i'm at in my career
and that's what's you know freed me up
and allowed me to
um you know to get to this comfort level
is is
uh is the piece that sometimes surpasses
even your own understanding
in um i don't have bitterness towards
the organization or jordan or anything
associate with that i'm just i've been
working on myself and
i think a lot of times when people you
know see whether it's a narrative about
my
you know mental state or how i'm playing
you know they have to
they can't just it can't just be a
positive thing they have to say well
it's a shot at somebody or a slide at
somebody or he's got
he's trying to you know it's an fu to
somebody or whatever it might be
you know in this situation i really feel
like it's just i've i've been
choosing to work on myself um
during during quarantine and coped
lockdown
and uh you know i feel really good about
where i'm at matt and i have
you know we we've had a friendship since
the beginning i think it's
it's even grown uh during this off
season there's a lot of trust there and
we're in the second year of a system uh
that guys are just playing a little bit
faster and we're finding ways to be more
efficient
i mean that that doesn't maybe sell a
lot of uh papers or get a lot of hits on
the website but
to me that's uh that's closer to the
truth than
uh this idea of uh some monster chip so
in terms of your
your receiving mates then um do they
have one
because the concept that uh you didn't
get the help that was required because
your uh if you will successor was
drafted uh
speaks to the fact that they're not good
enough uh do they have that ship
i don't know rich i mean i think again i
think everybody has different ways of
being motivated and i think
you know alan lazar just had a plenty of
you know chips he could put on that
shoulder whether it's
jacksonville trying to make him a tight
end or us not letting him work with the
green group for the first whole first
training camp even though he was
dominating on the other side of the
field working against the twos and
threes or
the fact that we cut them or the fact
that we put him on the active roster and
didn't dress him and the fact that maybe
when we finally dressed him we didn't
play him so he's got
he's got plenty of things he can he can
have chips about
um marquez same thing i think marquez
you know his thing has always been about
his own confidence and
the more confident that he is the more
he can just relax and not put too much
pressure on himself
because i think he is such a talented
guy but
i've i have a lot of trust in in both of
those guys and obviously devonte
you'll still need to see some more from
some of the guys behind them but
buddy i'm proud of those guys the way
they've stepped up and and the training
camps they've had and how they've gotten
off to a good starts the first two games
and then the narrative about the
quarterback that's going to be across
the field from you uh in drew brees i'm
sure you've heard it uh coming off that
monday night game
uh i've i've likened this i don't
believe in this narrative i
i should say uh just to start but uh
i've likened it on this show that he's
like the bernie's at weekend at bernie's
that he's that
somebody's going to come out and prop
him up and throw the ball down the field
for him because he's basically
dead based on the first two weeks of his
performance what do you say
what you're hearing about what people
are saying about drew brees coming into
this matchup with you and drew on sunday
night on nbc
aaron well yeah look
i haven't seen a whole lot what's been
said i don't spend a tremendous amount
of my time
getting into some of these narratives
but i will say that
i you know definitely wednesday there
was some conversation
about it i think it's always a little
bit dangerous to
[Music]
to go after uh veteran hall of fame
quarterbacks uh two weeks in the season
i said i think i said on tuesday that
you know i remember a few years ago when
brady
got and and then patriots got beat up by
the chiefs and everybody said
you know brady's done and might be time
to you know play garoppolo and this is
the beginning of the end for those guys
and
i think he uh you know won a few super
bowls after that
and a lot of a lot of people a lot of
people ate some crow so i'd be uh
i think it's always it's always a
slippery slope to start going after
veteran quarterbacks early in the season
i bet so is there any narratives about
the media you want to throw at me aaron
it's fine do you want to do that i'm i'm
cool with that
yeah i'll wait till we're offline though
all right if you want to do that that's
all good hey we've had aaron jones on
here uh many times i love this
young man i love this kid he is just
dynamite i just think what he has turned
into and what he's turning himself into
has been
amazing what has it been from your
perspective aaron
it has been really really special to
watch
there's some guys who you just can't
help but pull for
because they do things the right way and
jonesy is one of those guys he's
he is one of the greatest teammates that
i've had in 16 years
he is the most respectful teammate
possibly
that we've ever had i mean he's still
yes sir no sir
uh to you know
so many people you know basically
everybody older than him around the
facility
he's just said to he's such a great kid
and he
is not jealous doesn't have any jealousy
he really cheers for his teammates
he pulls for him he blocks his ass off
he's obviously a great runner of the
football he can take it to the distance
he's worked hard on areas that he hasn't
you know that he's needed to improve on
whether it's route running
pass catching blocking understanding
certain
intricacies of the system um he's a
great representation of organization in
the community
um you know i think he's made some
mistakes he's owned up to him
and he is uh you know one of the
greatest uh
greatest young players we've got in our
locker room and and uh
such a such a great kid he can't help
but pull for him and
and just so proud of what he's
accomplished he adds so much to our team
he's such a dynamic player um and
an even better person so uh in a couple
minutes i have left with you uh one
football question one pop culture
football question if you could wave a
wand i asked this of belichick i've
asked this
of uh everybody else uh at the top of
the if you will
uh flow chart in many different ways
players and coaches
the last couple weeks um if you could
wave a wand and change a rule
in the nfl the aaron rodgers wand wave
and the rule would be what if you could
change one
in the nfl um
that's a good question um i love answers
that start that way aaron i really do
as a host thank you aaron um
i don't know i feel like that we've gone
a little bit overboard on
on some of the player safety and
taking out some of the some of the
collisions in the game that i felt like
made the game a little bit different and
and
just i think it's the the danger in the
game that people
the fans enjoy because you are putting
yourself at risk now i'm not talking
about
coming out with head hunting shots and
wanting any of those i just feel like
we've gone a little bit overboard with
what is deemed as blindside blocks i
think we've gone overboard on hitting of
quarterbacks
you know love taps in the helmet are 15
yards uh
you know i think there's some dirty
plays that have gotten out of league as
far as guys going low on quarterbacks
but
you know i do think there are some some
of those plays
and i haven't i don't feel like i've
gotten a ton of roughing the passer
penalties over my years but
i'm definitely not usually bitching for
once because i feel like
you know some of those hits are part of
the game and i think
you know we have taken out some of the
dangerous
uh head hunting shots but i think
um there's some that have gotten a
little soft in my opinion that
that we might need to look at especially
some of these
blindside they're calling blindside
blocks that maybe a lineman is making
protecting the quarterback or receivers
making that
um i don't know i think we've got a
little bit too far down the line on some
of those okay
what you and what are you binge watching
or what did you you mentioned during the
quarantine you said you were working on
yourself outside of that whenever you
had spare time
binge watching what what is aaron
rodgers uh aaron rodgers binge watching
well i'm a big ricky gervais fan so i
binge watched after life season two
okay then went back and watched one and
two again
um i'm on my second time through the
office
uh the british the british version i
love the british office i've seen that
a few times through but i'm i'm back on
the american office
again i'm on season seven
second time through since uh since march
i've got a lot of recommendations but i
don't have a lot of time and
not now sure yeah and 22 minutes for an
episode of the office is uh
pretty nice so what's your go-to office
episode aaron rodgers you say that this
is it if anybody wants to watch the
office this is the one that's your
favorite what do you got for me oh
it's so hard i think it's michael and
jan
host a dinner party when they invite
over
jim and pam and angela and andy and then
dwight shows up with his babysitter
and the scene where michael's talking
about the plasma tv and how he can pull
it away from the wall and push it back
in
is unbelievable and then spoiler alert
jan
you know breaks it with one of his
dundees there's just so much to that
episode
it's so ridiculous but that's got to be
one of my all-time favorites for sure
because as you know you know bumgarner's
of a huge packer fan you make him happy
so i guess it's only
right that uh what he did makes you
happy it's it's just a circle of life
uh uh let me sneak this in do we see
devonte adams sunday
aaron is there any concern i don't know
i wouldn't rule him out i
definitely wouldn't rule him out you
know he hasn't been practicing a whole
lot but uh
but i think you know if anybody can do
it it's him i know he i know he wants to
but we'll see how he's feeling tomorrow
morning
okay aaron thank you for the call what
do you what what do you want me to ask
aaron rodgers do you see before we let
her go chris
the golfing or something like that well
brian bumgarner oh we have brian yeah
brian said that uh
that uh oh my god something about
golfing mirror
and strokes and things of that nature
he's been yeah he's been telling
everybody that he's finally finishing
the positive at tahoe after
all these years of battling barkley for
last place he kind of
he finally finished in the middle of the
pack for the first time ever in tahoe
okay
so okay that should that's we'll we'll
read between those lines
for three straight days that's what he's
cheering about he's now he's high
stepping
uh aaron thanks for the call always
greatly appreciate it always enjoy our
chats you keep crushing it and
let's uh stay in touch down the line
likewise buddy
you got it it's aaron rodgers green bay
packers